[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome to Google I/O 2017,
our Annual Developer Festival.
I'm Timothy Jordan, a
developer advocate at Google.
And I'll be touring the I/O
venue throughout the next three
days, exploring the sandboxes,
interviewing Googlers,
and giving you
eyes on the ground.
That's right.
Even though you're joining
remotely, this year,
you'll get an in-depth
look at everything
happening at Shoreline,
not just the sessions.
You can follow along on any
of the live stream channels
on google.com/io.
Google I/O is an outdoor
developer festival
hosting 7,200 attendees
at Shoreline Amphitheater,
along with millions of
viewers on the live stream--
that's you-- and
thousands of developers
and more than 450 local
I/O Extended events
across 80 countries.
We have 14 content tracks with
over 150 breakout sessions,
all live-streamed
on google.com/io.
There's also over
70 code labs live,
to get you up and running
with our latest APIs today
at g.co/io/codelabs.
But before you get to
any of that, let's review
a handful of the
announcements you just heard.
Smart Reply, available in
inbox by Gmail and Allo,
saves you time by
suggesting quick responses
to your messages.
It utilizes machine learning
to give you better responses
the more you use it.
And it already drives 12% of
replies in Inbox on mobile.
Starting today, Smart
Reply is coming to Gmail
for Android and iOS too.
We're excited to announce that
our second generation tensor
processing units are coming to
Google Compute Engine as cloud
TPUs where you can connect
them to virtual machines
of all shapes and sizes
and mix and match them
with other types of
hardware, including
Skylake CPUs and Invidia GPUs.
You can program these
cloud TPUs with TensorFlow,
the most popular
open source machine
learning framework on GitHub.
And we're introducing
high level APIs,
which will make it easier to
train machine-learning models
on CPUs, GPUs, or cloud TPUs
with only minimal code changes.
Many top researchers
don't have access
to anywhere near as much
compute power as they need.
To help as many
researchers as we can
and further accelerate the
pace of open machine-learning
research, we will
make 1,000 cloud TPUs
available at no cost to ML
researchers via the TensorFlow
research cloud.
Android O, coming
later this year,
will bring more
fluid experiences
to your smaller screen,
as well as improvements
to battery life and security.
With picture-in-picture,
you can seamlessly
do two tasks simultaneously.
And smart text selection
improves copy and paste
by using machine learning
to recognize entities
on the screen.
Google Play Protect is Google's
comprehensive security services
for Android, which provides
powerful new protections
and greater visibility
into your device security.
Play Protect is built into
every device with Google Play,
is always updating,
and automatically
takes action to keep your
data and device safe.
We also have an early
preview of a new initiative
for entry level Android
devices that internally we
call Android Go.
The goal is to get computing
into the hands of more people
by creating a great smartphone
experience on all Android
devices with one gigabyte
or less of memory.
Android Go is designed with
features relevant for people
who have limited
data connectivity
and speak multiple languages.
Of course, way more was
covered in the Google keynote,
including new ways to share with
Google Photos, including photo
books; new ways that Google
Assistant can help you do even
more; investments in
the core technologies
that enable VR and AR,
and in platforms that make
them accessible to more people.
Have questions about I/O '17?
Tweet them, starting
today through May 19,
using #io17request.
A team of Googlers will be
on-site chasing down answers
for you.
Make sure to also follow
the conversation on #io17
and on the Google
Developers blog.
Make sure to tune into
the developer keynote
at 1:00 PM Pacific time.
And I'll see you right
here on the Livestream
between all the sessions.
This is Google I/O 2017.
[MUSIC PLAYING]